c'est qu'on entend des bruits bah chez
lui alors qu'il habite plus là-bas des
chaises qui bougent bon après on a cru
qu'il y avait des gens des squatteurs
qui habitaient là-bas mais pas du tout
en fait c'est à dire que les phénomènes
ils continuent et les gens de l'immeuble
ils sont toujours terrassés
terrorisé et son voilà donc qu'est-ce
qui se passe que il arrive à ils vivent
maintenant ils s'y font parce que c'est
depuis 2019 ça fait trois ans est-ce
qu'ils arrivent à s'y faire ou est-ce
que c'est compliqué toujours Monsieur le
Maire c'est compliqué pour eux oui bien
sûr alors vous avez constaté ces
phénomènes paranormaux non non d'accord
je suis rendu sur place mais je ne les
ai pas constaté d'accord bon je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité parce que je
pense qu'il faut clarifier quand même
certaines choses je lis j'entends
beaucoup de choses depuis 48 heures
moi j'ai bien sûr reçu mes concitoyens
fantaisiens qui étaient les situations
difficiles il était très affectée parce
qu'il se passe dans la cage d'escalier
ça c'était en juillet alors est-ce que
vous pouvez rappeler à noter les
spectateurs ce qui s'y passe est-ce
qu'on vous raconte de ce qui se passe
dans cette immeuble juste après et après
on va revenir sur sur tout ce qu'on dit
dans la presse mais qu'est-ce qui se
passe il vous dit quoi qui vient d'être
dit par mon jeune collègue font plaisir
que oui il y a des gens qui rapportent
des bruits de chaises des bruits de
musique qu'ils entendent qui étaient
c'est la musique que écouter
effectivement la personne disparue des
sensations de présence des des
grincements voilà donc tout ça c'est un
ensemble de lumière parfois qui
s'allument toute seule bon voilà mais
moi je c'est ce qui est rapporté encore
beaucoup d'habitants qui qui alors moi
j'ai reçu 10 locataires donc quatre ou
cinq étaient vraiment très concernés par
cette affaire et très affectée
d'ailleurs dans leur vie de tous les
jours c'est quoi c'est c'est c'est c'est
galère en Walid parce que
c'est galère mais
ce que ce que je constate aujourd'hui
c'est que le maire il se donne il se
donne les moyens il nous aide c'est à
dire qu'il a pas laissé la faire passer
comme ça la prise au sérieux et il la
traite ce que je tiens à remercier
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'il a fait
monsieur le maire depuis que ça dure ça
depuis 3 ans que vous avez fait Monsieur
le Maire pour que face à cette situation
qui est quand même extrêmement vraiment
c'est c'est passé
en ordre Busters
vous avez fait quoi alors on a surtout
accompagné en fait on a essayé d'apaiser
d'accompagner
moi je dis que on ferait appel à des
gens pour faire un exercice évidemment
non alors c'est quoi on est dans une
mairie qui est laïque on est en France
et donc on est absolument pas ça nos
compétences il est mort de mort violente
ça c'est important je ne sais pas en
tout cas ce n'est pas ce n'est pas dans
nos compétences de d'organiser un
exorcisme
qu'un prêtre et un imam était réuni pour
exorciser cet immeuble longé est-ce que
c'est vrai ou pas alors pour l'instant
moi j'ai pas de notion qui soit passé
mais moi en fait ce que j'ai fait c'est
que après avoir écouté mes concitoyens
j'ai transmis l'info de ce souhait du
passage d'un imam et d'un prêtre aux
autorités religieuses qui sont
concernées après le rôle de la mairie
s'arrête là parce que la mairie a pas
compétence pour faire plus et les
locataires est-ce qu'ils ont appelé des
gens pour exorciser l'immeuble il y a
beaucoup de choses fausses qui se disent
sur sur les réseaux et sur les journaux
et j'envoie j'envoie tous les jours
c'est quoi bah ils disent que bah déjà
ils disent que il y a imam et un prêtre
qui allait venir Monsieur le Maire
n'était pas au courant nous non plus et
on l'a pas vu d'accord on a pas une on a
ni vu de mais de prêtre ni de imam
dans l'immeuble maintenant c'est voilà
c'est une mairie de laïque donc
franchement après voilà il y a des
solutions j'ai peut-être qu'ils essaient
de trouver toutes les solutions aussi
possibles pour éradiquer cette
c'est voilà cet esprit je sais pas voilà
est-ce que est-ce que vous y croyez vous
ici je dois tuer quoi tu est-ce que vous
Monsieur le Maire vous y croyez à cette
affaire après je ne crois pas à la
réalité des fantômes non d'accord bon je
suis non croyant non pratiquant je suis
scientifique de formation donc je n'y
crois pas par contre ça veut pas dire
qu'il faut pas respecter ça parce que
alors ça peut être quoi respecter toutes
les croyances toutes les impressions
toutes les expériences qui ne se
rapportent des réponses cartésiennes à
ce qui se passe
la principale réponse cartésienne tu
veux dire c'est que tout le quartier va
fait l'objet d'une opération de
déconstruction reconstruction et que de
toute façon tous les habitants qui sont
là seront relogés dans le cadre de cette
opération de construction non mais juste
donc on peut espérer que il y a
c'est quoi c'est des musiques la musique
de la personne vous entendez des bruits
de chaise vous entendez c'est quoi ce
qu'il y a des trucs qui qui voilà est-ce
qu'il y a des des choses qui peuvent qui
peuvent être plus graves dans ce qui se
passe dans cet immeuble est-ce que parce
que nous on imagine l'esprit on imagine
des choses encore plus graves est-ce
qu'il y a des choses graves qui s'y
passent
je vois des gens qui arrivent plus à
sortir de chez eux c'est ça leur touche
personnellement c'est quelque chose
parce qu'au contraire en fait il devrait
non mais ils ont peur ils ont peur ça se
passe ça se passe dans la cage
d'escalier ah d'accord voilà exactement
et
ça remonte aussi dans les appartements
quelquefois il y a des gens qui font que
dans la cage d'escalier exactement quand
on entend des bruits c'est à l'extérieur
c'est à l'extérieur du de la part de
l'appartement c'est ça c'est dire que et
ça les terroriste complètement mais
c'est bon c'est l'après-midi c'est le
soir c'est quand c'est le soir c'est
qu'on a la nuit oui pendant la nuit
des enregistrements
personne n'a filé une personne parce que
c'est vrai que ça dure depuis 3 ans
cette affaire à un moment un moment
est-ce qu'on peut pas voir vraiment ce
qui se passe en plus pour virer quand
même tout un immeuble et leur locataire
c'est que vous prenez la chose aussi on
peut pas les filmer nous toute une nuit
on dort là-bas
je peux vous héberger les uns ou les
autres
quand Jean Didier était venu la dernière
fois parce qu'il était venu en même
temps que vous c'est le voyant était
venu en même temps que vous et il était
revenu une autre fois pour parler
d'autre chose dans le couloir en sortant
j'ai marché avec lui et je lui ai
demandé des nouvelles de votre immeuble
je lui ai dit comme il avait proposé de
venir faire quelque chose je dis est-ce
que vous avez été pour pour ces gens et
il m'a dit qu'il avait proposé de son
aide gratuitement et que personne
n'avait accepté ou voulu le faire venir
et du coup
voilà on se demandait même si c'était
vraiment réel parce que il proposait ça
gratuitement en plus donc voilà est-ce
que vous l'avez connu
on est sur une première question t'es
pas sur RFM ici c'est
le temps je sais que sur la femme vous
êtes toujours pressé pour faire de
l'audience vous ne faites pas mais ici
c'est RFM ben tu vas voir mon chéri tu
vas voir là c'est pratiquement zéro le
néon
merci alors personnellement je n'ai pas
eu de nouvelles bah je n'ai pas eu de
nouvelles de lui il m'a pas du tout
contacté alors que j'étais la personne
principale concernée c'est moi qui alors
passer sur le plateau etc donc parce que
justement il y a Gisèle exactement qui
elle n'en peut plus regarder
chien sont bien rangés et tu trouves des
chaises déplacées les assiettes qui qui
se déplacent toutes seules les ampoules
qui s'éteints qui s'allument toute seule
c'est c'est des choses vraiment que qui
font peur on dort pas la nuit mon fils
de 14 ans il dort avec moi dans ma
chambre aujourd'hui parce que les nuits
il y a quelqu'un qui lui s'appuyait les
les pieds
je confirme c'est bien dans la rue de
Daniel Moreau
[Applaudissements]
on en rigole mais Gisèle elles sont
vraiment non mais c'est incroyable
juste aujourd'hui
parce que c'est vrai qu'il faut aller
peut-être filmer il faut voir si c'est
ce qui se passe qui c'est fou moi j'ai
une question pour Monsieur le Maire on a
l'impression que cette affaire elle vous
embarrasse beaucoup parce que d'un côté
vous respectez la détresse de vos
habitants vous voulez pas vous les
mettre un dos mais on a l'impression
qu'au fond de vous vous pensez que c'est
complètement bidon tout ça
ah non c'est surtout qu'on aborde on n'a
pas beaucoup de moyens pour agir parce
que
je pense c'est qu'il y a de toute façon
quelque chose qui se passe parce que ça
c'est objectif on n'a pas une pétition
de 10 personnes qui viennent vous voir
alors que de toute façon le logement
encore une fois il est prévu puisqu'on
est dans une opération de reconstruction
et qui et qui visiblement sont très
affectés parce qu'il se passe sans qu'il
y ait une raison alors voilà après moi
on a regardé les côtés habitat pour voir
si on pouvait regarder expertiser un
petit peu le bâtiment c'est vrai que
c'est l'habitat a des procédures de
relogement donc il a examiné chacune des
situations pour voir si les choses
pouvaient suivre leurs cours en même
temps il peut pas y avoir non plus de
passe-droit parce que sinon ce que vous
disiez quand personne n'a répondu moi je
comprends parce que vous savez à quel
moment où cet effet est devenu
médiatique les habitants ils ont reçu
mais des centaines de coups de fil et la
télé brésilienne qui est venue il y a
des gens qui les ont harcelés pendant
les jours et des jours pour leur
proposer oui oui mais voyons
de vous mais on fait rien alors
comme ça et voilà il est pas une
histoire d'alarme aussi qu'il y a un
truc qui s'est passé avec une alarme si
c'est ça
l'histoire en fait elle s'est passé
c'est passé un mois après que je passe
sur TPMP c'est c'est des squatteurs qui
ont essayé de bon c'est des voisins qui
ont expliqué bon moi j'étais pas là mais
ils expliquait qu'il y avait des
squatteurs qui ont essayé de rentrer
dans l'appartement et quand ils ont
essayé d'ouvrir je sais pas comment ils
ont réussi à ouvrir une alarme s'est
déclenchée dans tout l'immeuble c'est à
dire dans le hall et ça bon tout le
monde l'a entendu dans l'immeuble et les
squatteurs ont couru parce qu'ils ont
cru que voilà quoi mais ce qu'elle
existe cette alarme dans l'immeuble mais
pour le feu pour autre chose exactement
c'est à dire que après
nous on en a pas parlé comme ça parce
qu'on s'est dit bon c'est peut-être ça
il y a peut-être que les alarmes de feu
etc mais il y a eu un un des voisins qui
est parti courser la personne le
squatter il lui a demandé qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé etc il doit être dit non moi
je cherche pas de problème moi je suis
venu juste rentrer ici parce que voilà
j'ai pas où dormir etc mais il y a une
grosse alarme qui est et tout le monde
l'a entendu et après parce que là ils
ont commencé à faire déménager enfin
enlever tout ce qui avait à l'intérieur
du bâtiment là dans l'appartement et on
a demandé à gardienne est-ce qu'il y a
une alarme qui est installée ici quand
on ouvre la porte ou quoi elle nous a
dit explique elle nous a expliqué
clairement qu'il n'y avait rien il n'y
avait pas d'alarme et on a vérifié parce
que on sait que quand
l'opération du Saint-Esprit je sais pas
du tout qui n'existe pas c'est fou en
tout cas j'ai vérifié j'ai regardé
Monsieur le Maire aujourd'hui donc il y
a rien à faire pour pour cet immeuble je
suis pas un expert en paranormal mais ce
qui est sûr c'est que nous ce qu'on
essaie de faire c'est d'abord
d'accompagner effectivement
tous les habitants et puis bah petit à
petit le le phénomène de relogement va
progressivement
toute la cité va être construite
dans trois ans
ils vont casser beaucoup d'assiette
dans cet appartement qui est que des
locations dans la dans l'immeuble où il
y a des propriétaires c'est que des
locations alors cet appartement qui est
vide qui fait bouger des singes qui fait
allumer des lumières tout seul pourquoi
on mettrait pas un locataire dedans au
lieu de le laisser vide alors quand vous
mettez pas quelqu'un dedans
les logements qui se libèrent comme ça
après un décès soit on a les héritiers
et à ce moment-là le bailleur que c'est
le bailleur qui fait tout ça
d'ailleurs
soit on peut vider rapidement et à ce
problème là notre locataire qui arrive
soit il y a des problèmes parfois de
succession on trouve pas la famille à ce
moment-là il y a un problème avec les
meubles qui sont sur place et ça peut
prendre un peu de temps j'ai aussi
demandé au bailleur qu'on accélère les
choses en vide l'appartement
les tribus
trois ans c'est vrai pour 3 ans c'est
quand même extrêmement long pour pour
voilà pour la destruction de l'immeuble
et c'est vrai qu'ils vont pas rester 3
ans comme ça à vivre comme ça c'est vrai
que c'est compliqué je sais pas faudrait
peut-être aussi envoyer peut-être des
gens qui qui qui enregistre qui qui
filme surtout parce que au moins c'est
vrai que là ça fait 3 ans que j'aurais
peut-être faire ça je sais pas voilà
c'est c'est c'est rien à faire et
peut-être le soir aller mettre quelqu'un
dans la équipe dans la cage d'escalier
pour voir si ça se produit les
phénomènes paranormaux pour aller voilà
pour essayer d'avancer je sais pas après
j'avais j'ai su que y avait une il y
avait une voisine juste en face de la
personne qui était bon bah l'appartement
ok elle se plaignait à la mairie bon ça
fait ça devait faire ça je sais pas
combien de temps mais se plaignait de
phénomène etc avant avant il la primit
pour une folle bon je sais pas comment
ça se passait etc mais ils l'ont fait
déménager c'est-à-dire qu'elle habite
plus là-bas d'accord ils ont réussi à la
faire déménager etc c'était la personne
qui habitait juste en face du de
l'appartement maintenant le truc qui est
fou c'est qu'il est pas une autorité qui
est constatée ces phénomènes paranormaux
Nissa et Monsieur le Maire aussi je sais
que vous faites beaucoup mais je
comprends pas pourquoi vous ne militez
pas vous refusez le prêtre et l'imam
parce que c'est des exorcistes qui sont
très connus sur des maisons hantées
très connue on fait pas appel aux
autorités religieuses attention moi je
ne refuse pas le patrimoine simplement
j'ai transmis l'information auprès de
l'imam et après c'est une affaire qui
redevient du droit privé moi j'ai pas le
droit en tant que mère d'organiser une
cérémonie religieuse dans lequel
d'escalier c'est pas normal
ligne budgétaire une ligne budgétaire
par exemple
merci en tout cas on va suivre cette
affaire merci beaucoup Monsieur le Maire
merci Walid d'avoir été avec nous